I suppose in this case I'll be ranking
the film's from impressive to most
impressive
[Music]
alright so I have not done this before
at all actually so lately I've been sort
of doing redos on some of my earlier
lists from before I had like any
subscribers but this one's new I
actually haven't done a ranking of the
Star Wars movies before and so I'm gonna
do that I waited a little while to do
this because I wanted to see solo and
this seemed like a good time to do it I
mean
episode 9 is not out yet so we don't
have the completed saga but we're a year
and a half away from getting Episode
nine this seems like about as good a
time as any so with that in mind let's
do this we're gonna go from the bottom
up to the top and oh so conveniently
there's ten of these so starting at the
bottom number 10 episode 1 The Phantom
Menace so oh boy I I had a long
drawn-out sort of battle with myself as
to what goes at the bottom either this
or the next one because a lot of friends
I have put the next movie I'm gonna talk
about at the very bottom and rank this
slightly above it I just can't I can't I
can't in all good conscience 'no sir
italy there are only two good things
about this movie there is the Darth Maul
fight and there's the soundtrack and
that's it the special effects were okay
at the time I mean they were kind of
impressive insofar as they looked sort
of knew but they didn't even really look
convincing
the time you know Anakin I don't want to
I don't want to harp too much on Jake
Lloyd because no kid they could have had
Haley Joel Osment who you know was a
phenomenal you know as a young actor but
holy crap nobody could have made good
you could have made good on those lines
and this script was atrocious it reads
like a first draft script it's really
amateur hour and I think that really
shows the problem with having George
Lucas be George Lucas at that point I
mean who who was gonna tell him no
nobody and and we see what happened and
and and I think happiness came out we
got a much clearer picture of how much
the original trilogy
was all his original core ideas but were
being filtered and tempered by other
people around them and this is basically
just this is this is uncut Lucas and
it's not good the Jar Jar Binks the
midi-chlorians that honestly that's
probably the biggest problem I have with
this thing if I'm to single out one
single thing I know some people will say
that the podrace is good except that
it's too long and it's dull it's kind of
exciting to see in a theatre try
watching at home
if you have it in a while it's kind of
dull yeah Darth Maul looks cool and the
fights you know neat and the music's
really good props and John Williams
that's it
that's all this thing is going forward
moving up to number nine the one that I
said most of most of my friends consider
to be the worst one and that's episode
two attack of the clones so the thing is
we'll attack of the clones and this this
is a debate I will be having again with
myself with the ranking of a couple of
other things on this list but you know
it was an argument of there are a couple
of high points in episode 1 only two to
my reckoning but they do exist whereas
Attack of the Clones is a whole lot of
it's a white noise of a movie and I know
everyone is like meme to the heck out of
the hates and thing but honestly in an
in the movie itself is like it doesn't
stand out as much as you'd think it
doesn't stand out as a oh my god this
part it's so bad I mean it's weird and
awkward but most of the movies where it
just sort of stays at this one level
throughout the whole thing I'll admit to
kind of liking the Yoda fight I friends
hate that I it's okay but even that like
it's not as good as the Darth Maul fight
and the music's fine but there's nothing
as memorable here as duel of the fates
was so it doesn't have the highs limited
though they are of episode 1 but it also
doesn't have anything as soul-crushing
as 10 year old Anakin or midi-chlorians
or Georgia big wild technically
announced Jar Jar Binks he's there but
he's been told away back or cut out a
lot a lot of his screen time cuts so
yeah this this just edges out up sowed
one to come in at number nine and now as
we get into 8 and 7 it's the next two
movies where I had a very similar debate
and ended up sort of doing the opposite
that I just did here so I guess you can
consider me consistently inconsistent so
number eight solo solo is not a bad
movie but I'm hard-pressed to tell you
what's good about it there's not a lot
wrong with it there's not a lot that's
actually bad I think the Darth Maul
reveal was dumb because it doesn't make
sense unless you are a hardcore fan of
the TV shows which most people aren't
I'm sorry I mean I'm sure it was very
cool for those of you that you did know
but for the rest of us it was a great
big what the hell you know but even but
aside from that like it's not it's not
bad there's really nothing especially
wrong with it but there's just nothing
especially great about it though there
aren't really any moments that make you
go oh yeah
ah that right there it's got a pretty
good cast that does pretty well
chewy anion of decent chemistry what he
Harrelson was good you know Donald
Glover was good but it doesn't add up to
much these few good components don't
really feel like they get a chance to
shine in a meaningful way
and this is a movie I've seen twice
because you know I saw when I first came
out and then I saw it again cuz my
mother wanted to see it and it's I
didn't I didn't regret seeing it a
second time but you know what are you
gonna do so that brings us to number
seven which as I said and even as I'm
recording as part of these debating
should I swap these back but I'm just
god I'm just gonna stick with it know
that they are basically neck-and-neck
seven and eight are basically a tie but
they're just bad for did they're just
low on the list for different reasons so
number seven is the last Jedi my
problems with the last Jedi because I
have them and they are numerous are not
the problems most people have with last
Jedi I don't have a problem with this
depiction of Luke I don't have a problem
with Leia flying through space I don't
have a problem with array I think kylo
Ren is awesome in this you know I I
don't have the big problems that most
fans who really dislike this movie have
with it that being said it's
structurally a mess some of the
characters act really stupidly rose and
Adam a whole dough being a couple of the
big ones the entire Kanto bite thing
it's not just a matter of like oh and
there's more this road stuff and they
bring up all the children and SJW you
animal right it's nothing like that
it's just structurally pointless it's a
complete divergence it's a side quest
with no stakes so that entire thing
doesn't work there's a whole bunch of
things that I dig the concept of but the
execution is one
yeah at the same time there's stuff that
I genuinely love in this movie I love
what is being done with kylo Ren I love
that throne-room fight you know there's
there are a number of things that happen
across this movie that I really think
are phenomenal and then there's the lows
that just sink the whole dang thing so
this is a bit like as I said with attack
of the clones and Phantom Menace we're
going between this and solo one is more
just mediocre and the other has higher
highs but lower lows and in this case I
did go the other way but like you really
I really do they're practically tied but
it's because I am genuinely impressed by
the parts that work in this movie cuz I
really enjoy them I just wish they were
they were in a better movie overall next
up number 6 episode 3 Revenge of the
Sith I actually do enjoy this movie like
uh ironically I enjoyed this movie I
have fun with it and I think the tension
is decent I think the fall of Anakin is
slightly clunky slightly ham-fisted but
it works for me for a big overblown
space opera I think it works and I love
the I like the fight I love was an
overstatement but I liked the fight
between Anakin and obi-wan they one of
them needed to have a different colour
lightsaber but aside from that I liked
that because there was a good emotional
resonance to it that I appreciated
honestly the order 66 sequence that that
choked me up first time I saw it the
moment that choked me up was was Yoda
falling to his knees and the music kinda
swells and you're realizing he's feeling
the deaths of his friends
I choked up seeing that like it works
it's genuinely powerful I think the the
while the overall fall of Anakin is a
little bit clunky I think that the
seduction scene with the the tale of
Darth Plagueis the wise and all of that
people can say how awkward it is but
again for the kind of stories that Star
Wars are I think it works and it's a
nice slow paced quieter moment the
action in this is is better they it
feels like they integrate the CGI better
overall and it's not as sectioned off
and very clearly here's the CGI here's
the real people's stuff I enjoyed this
movie it's not great it's got plenty of
problems that still is Darth Vader going
no which is awful and even its highs
aren't amazing but this is what I would
I will pop in for pleasure all for the
ones I've listed below this even though
ones that I've seen more than once I
don't really have a desire to see any of
those again from however many times I've
seen them up to this point I enjoy
watching this one I'll still pop it in
so moving on up to number five we come
to rogue one this is one where if if I
couldn't see the stitches from the
troubled development of it then it would
have had it almost definitely would have
been higher because the first really
definitely the first act maybe the first
two acts are clunky and awkwardly
stitched together basically up until
they get to the planet where jennarose
father dies
up until then it's just sort of jumping
along from plot point to plot point some
of which don't really need to be in
there the whole thing with Forest
Whitaker's character like I appreciate
lighting
versus say the Darth Maul thing from
solo I appreciate that this was a better
way to pull the character from the you
know the
or whatever because you didn't need to
know he came from that for him to make
sense as a character that said he still
didn't add a lot and and so that that
was kind of a necessary but that third
act man that third act is gangbusters as
they get there and watching this team
get whittled down as they start to fall
to accomplish this mission and then of
course as a wonderful little icing on
the cake we get we get Vader and the
most badass mode he has ever been in and
yeah I like this one again if it had a
smoother front end it could have been a
lot higher number for episode 7 the
force awakens I enjoyed this movie it
has become oddly fashionable I think
largely in the wake of the divided
opinion on the last Jedi to crap on this
movie and I think that's wrong the
movies not perfect especially in light
of light is very obvious that it's
setting up some stuff that either
doesn't pay off or pays off in like an
anti pay off which i think is just poor
delivery of some of these concepts but
take it as a film unto itself
I love the pacing I love the flow
I like the dialogue and the feel of the
new characters I love Poe and Finn
together they're they're terrific I like
Ray I don't have a problem with Wright
actually in either movie I definitely
don't have a problem with her here I
think I Harrison Ford is not sleeping
through this movie which he kind of
tends to do these days but he's awake
he's alert he's present he's good and
you know it looks and feels like Star
Wars it's exciting to have back and I I
think it's a good time it is proving to
not be as well planned out overall as as
I would have liked to now be feeling
having seen the next entry but I still
like I I don't own the last Jedi I
probably never will I do own this and I
watch this I like it so nobody's
surprised we have got the top the top
three are taken up with the original
trilogy so let's get this on the way
number three Return of the Jedi
really the only complaint I can level
against this one would be the Ewoks and
even then I don't have a problem with
the fact that the Ewoks are cute I think
what they should have done with the
Ewoks wasn't that they won through tween
as' and you know logs versus high-tech
weaponry I think they should have won
through Zulu tactics ie sheer numbers
they should have been swarming all over
those stormtroopers like ants you know
that that would have been the way I
would have gone with it of course I
would have been more expensive but I
think pretty much all of this works like
the one criticism I've heard about it
and I don't necessarily share it but I
get it is that this feels like Luke's
movie whereas the franchise up to this
point has felt more like ensemble
especially by the end of of Empire
Strikes Back it felt like it we were
dealing with all these characters and
everybody kind of gets sidelined so that
we can wrap up Luke's story specifically
and I hear that but at the same time I
think that plays out so well like that
final fight between him and Vader
which is actually my favourite
lightsabre battle
not because it's especially visually
arresting it's solid its competent but I
love the contrast of the red and green I
love the music that plays during their
fight and I love the emotion behind this
I love that luke beats him not through
not through taking the higher ground
which he tries to do but it doesn't work
and he
let's loose he beats Vader down brutally
but then realizes what he didn't takes a
step back and I like that
I think the the space fights are all
good you know the whole thing at Jabba's
palace is it's a bit of a divergence in
terms of the overall in there that this
thing is going for but man it's cool
man it's awesome like I just I just good
time with this one so the top two you
know what they are so I'm gonna tell you
the second one now at this point I'm
also gonna make something clear
if you hadn't guessed this already there
is a difference between favorite and
best I make yeah I am doing this ranking
as my favorites while in knowledge about
what I haven't number two is the best
Star Wars movie in terms of being a
complete and experienced writing
directing visuals acting the works
number two is the Empire Strikes Back
because it is the best it is the best
movie it's the best made it's the best
written it's the best acted it's one of
its maybe it's not the best looking but
it's up there among the best looking
it's the best looking of the original
trilogy definitely and I think it is is
a really phenomenal achievement in terms
of what it was able to do to make the
world of the original film bigger and
yet make the story more personal that is
that is an impressive balancing act to
be able to pull off and it it is the
best Star Wars movie from any objective
measure but it's not my favorite my
favorites episode for a new hope and I
think it's just because it has the stuff
that captured my imagination the most
and honestly a probably more than
anything comes down to the trench front
because when I was little and I would
quote unquote play Star Wars
because I didn't have I didn't have Star
Wars toys I wasn't like denied them or
anything but you gave me the choice I
usually went for him and I was like I've
got Star Wars tours of this big and I've
got a he-man toy this big yeah I'm going
for that but what I would pretend that I
was in Star Wars I was in a TIE fighter
I was in an x-wing I was working the gun
tour turrets on the Millennium Falcon
when I was a kid I used to we used to go
to the fourth of July
and to see the fireworks and my I went
with my mother my grandparents they
would lay out a blanket for me and I
would lay down and I'd watch the
fireworks and I would I actually would
do this picturing that I was working the
the cannons on the money in Falcon and
that each explosion of a firework was me
blowing up another ship the things that
in my mind are truly Star Wars because I
look I love I liked lightsabers I liked
the force I like all that stuff but the
the the sense of adventure and the space
enos of it I feel is that its purest in
the original film because it is much
more than any others it is an adventure
because you know Empire Strikes Back
it gets very personal it gets very heavy
and then Return of the Jedi its it's
wrapping that up it's still dealing
largely with the personal stories it's
about dealing with the consequences it's
about trying to change fate it's about
family the first ones it's just a fun
adventure it's like you stumbled across
you stumbled across a distress signal
like you kid they basically Luke comes
across a message in a bottle goes on an
adventure to rescue a princess and then
destroys the enemies base that's just
rollicking adventure and that to me is
started or at least that's
my Star Wars I'm not gonna say
differently that is what Star Wars is
but that's what Star Wars is for me is
that sense of adventure that I think has
not been captured in quite the same way
by any other film in the franchise and
so that is why a new hope it's my number
one favorite Star Wars movie what do you
think about this list how wrong am i
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do such as like and subscribe and
support me on patreon follow me on
Twitter and listen to a blood gas sends
something to the PIO box I don't know I
never plug that links for all that stuff
is down in the description so until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]